thank you to audible for sponsoring this
video audible keeps you informed
inspired and entertained baby you'll
finish more stories when you listen with
audibles you'll always be in all those
conversations your friends talk about
don't be left out baby with the
convenient audible app you can listen
anytime anyplace in your car in your ear
whether it out the gym shopping getting
your back you can't really listen
without able yep audible members can
exchange any title at any time start
listening today with the 30-day audible
trial three Oh mm-hmm
choose one audiobook and two audible
originals absolutely free visit
audible.com slash JK news or you could
text JK news to 500 500
I just recently downloaded this audio
book called what you do is who you are
oh it's a book by Ben Horowitz and super
cool because it teaches you how to be as
a business owner build a culture that
can help you survive good and bad times
fun fact JK was built during the
recession you can find this audiobook
and countless others when you start your
free audible trial today it is free
mmm-hmm
free free visit audible.com slash JK
news or text JK news to 500 500 or just
go ahead and click in a description box
below for that link and you to
ghostwrite bail Thank You audible for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
and me and your wedding is what
submitted by secret Hitler loving a
woman was shocked to find out why her
sister wanted their cousin to be in her
bridal party oh I heard about this one
this girl's off [ __ ] how many beat down
please say [ __ ] that way Oh an
actuality do you respects women I do
I heard you thought Nikki [ __ ] couple
times um I do she's your [ __ ] dumpster -
she is my [ __ ] dumpster I'm mostly call
come to dumpster respectfully just a
nice way to say that mm-hmm yeah so this
post was posted on reddit miv [ __ ]
which is all of our favorite so reddit
so it's titled bridezilla trying to use
scarred cousin as the ugly friend that's
why I don't have family and don't have
weddings we're taking a picture bridal
picture yeah and you get an ugly person
to be in the picture with you or Glee
person to make yourself look bomb yeah
it up proven that if you have an ugly
person in the picture it upgrades your
value they do a lot of studies because
there's a comparison you know that's why
I always have someone really poor
sitting next to me yeah
wait a minute V Choi he's the homeowner
so I'm the poor one yeah two things to
note at the top of this post this is an
alt account because I'm fairly sure my
sister monitors my main LOL also i know
that mister is an [ __ ] in general and
that's not what i'm asking for here i
want to know if it'd be a shitty move
for me to cross on earth so I would
grass on it yeah that means to grass on
someone is to scrape them on the ground
and leave that little stain bluegrass
ting fine
oh really wants to do that to her sister
used to have that on my jeans all the
time yeah not cuz I was like getting
doggy style or anything like that grass
is because you were getting done nobody
got that is because I was
yeah I was running around and sliding
man they continued
I was just sliding not getting dogs not
that we're getting doggy stuff negated
are you start at the park okay you're
welcome
you should show people examples like
getting Dargis out of the park not
getting values out of it yeah helpful
giving doggy style and not giving that's
true I just picture Joe like on a public
bus and then the guys aren't even paying
Joe any attention he goes I know which
is big you know that's from doggy style
for me getting around Joe turns again
assume you're not getting doggy cell all
right so they continue so eyes like as I
said just there my sister's not a very
nice person she's very entitled and
spoiled and it's honestly just kind of a
[ __ ] bully so it makes it okay for
her to be a [ __ ] I love when people do
that she was known for it at school and
it definitely hasn't stopped in her
adult life she's also getting married
soon oh joy we were both at Mom's house
the other day and she was talking about
her plans for her bridal party
she said she's having six bridesmaids
our little half-sister on dad's side
four of her close friends in our cousin
I was pretty shocked that she wanted the
cousin to be part of the bridal party
she's a really awesome person and
everything but I didn't think she and my
sister were close in fact I didn't think
she and my sister had even spoken for at
least a year or two turns out I was
right seeing mom and I were confused
sister laughed a bit and said imagine
how pretty we'll look in pictures with
her cousin has a lot of scarring down
one side of her face from an accident
when she was a kid she used to be
incredibly self-conscious about it as if
it is rather obvious and she but she's
more comfortable with herself these days
however I know her appearance her case
in point some rude some rude ass man in
a pub made a comment to her about it a
few months ago and she got really upset
and went into a depression for a couple
of weeks oh I don't want to upset her or
make her feel shitty but I'm also
totally disgusted though not surprised
by
sister and hate the idea of my cousin
being in the bridal party while the rest
of them were all laughing about her
behind her back however I'm scared that
if I tell her she'll have the same
reaction that she had to the knob head
in the pub plus she'll inevitably tell
my aunt what my sister said and it would
definitely cause family trauma not that
family drama
would it be a dick move for me to tell
her or is it the right thing to do dan
unstuffed
why would you tell her yeah why would
you tell her yeah what was she saying so
she so she knows that people are
laughing behind her back and she can at
least defend herself or not be around
that certainly she's aware but it's only
the sister no one in the audience is
talking [ __ ] the bridal party maybe
knows oh well at least like don't don't
be fooled by my sisters action like
she's not what she's using you yeah yeah
she's not buying her a hotel room your
passion wants you at the wedding
she's just watching the picture to make
a look hotter yeah what I want to know I
want to see how hot this chick is well
she's not that hot that's what I'm
saying yeah I wanna touch her intensely
oh we can't read it
decided that this poster is not the
[ __ ]
if she would tell her I I think I think
you know the real answer here is leave
your [ __ ] family I don't know man
what exactly do you mean horrible
[ __ ] sister oh I see yeah well yeah
why do people hold on to that [ __ ] I
don't know I don't know if the girl is
holding on to it I think it's just the
cousin that we're like yeah we're saying
she's going to a wedding
so who's the [ __ ] up [ __ ] here the
Citiz [ __ ] but yeah but is that her
sister is that her her cousin her huh
her cousins kind of like ugly one right
she's the scarred chick yeah yeah and in
so yeah so I was like I would I would
denounce my sisterhood yeah I don't
think I don't think the girl cares about
the sister she just sang she doesn't
want to cause me an impression and then
cause trauma within the family so she
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the system
wouldn't exposing got made fun of at a
bar she want to do the president for
services she cares about the cousin yeah
oh and then she's like how do I protect
her
the family she cares about how do I
protect her I would sabotage the [ __ ]
wedding I what so here's the thing how
would you sabotage me I would get a
bunch of people to be in the bridal
party okay critical flaw I would I would
really well first I don't like telling
people without giving them my support so
like if that's why I was initially
against like telling her cuz it's like
well if you can't help her through this
whole mess
you're gonna tell somebody you're gonna
abruptly like ruin their [ __ ] day
they don't know what to do with that and
that's the and then you're kind of like
we'll figure it out
and then you walk away right in my
situation if I it's either you don't
tell anyone at all you don't you don't
let them know you just let them [ __ ]
like have fun at the wedding and then if
some [ __ ] goes down you can kind of like
pull strings behind the scenes and then
let that person have a great experience
that they [ __ ] never know it happened
and then you tell him afterwards [ __ ]
that [ __ ] this is what she was doing
that's very different from before the
wedding then she builds up all this
anxiety and then she comes to the
wedding now feeling obligated to while
she knows she's the laughingstock that's
[ __ ] up oh I feel [ __ ] up not
telling her having to take all the
[ __ ] pictures and then tell her after
the fact the pictures forever see all
those pictures right there this was what
was behind that no no but then this is
what you do after when you do tell them
or during the wedding right so there's
many many options one option one op many
many good option though there's many
options one option is you if you tell
her to if you tell her before right you
conspire with her to [ __ ] ruin the
wedding and make sure that they get they
don't they don't have a wedding or they
make [ __ ] it they [ __ ] argue in front
of everybody
you tell other family members what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] this sister is so you
guys can [ __ ] ruin her wedding crazy I
think you'll ruin her wedding
but it's fun though what if you invite
all the hottest people on the earth to
the wedding because you have the ability
to let people into the wedding I'm sure
and they look really good and they take
photos with so [ __ ] hot that every
picture you're just looking at the hoppy
tell them to wear it's a white wedding
so all the girls were steamed is like a
clever comedy good I'm like a evil I'll
destroy you and [ __ ] traumatize you
for trying to traumatize good people
well it's fun what do you guys do what
for this oh yeah I would tell her in the
beginning just tell her straight yeah
and just be like make a [ __ ] that don't
even be in the pictures a bit if you are
make a [ __ ] up face on purpose
or pretend like the groom's [ __ ] you
or like grab titties like just [ __ ] up
every single picture
you wouldn't want to ruin their marriage
I would well their marriage is already
ruined cuz it girls such a piece of
trash does the guy know what a piece of
trash I'm sure yeah what about the
husband all right they might be
attracted to jokes because they're
brought dick faces I try to [ __ ] the
husband and make her [ __ ] jealous and
I'm not even gay oh you put your body
otherwise yeah last episode you said you
were getting doggy style mm-hmm I think
that was this episode so well bean grass
well let us know what episode it was
please I'll [ __ ] seduce this [ __ ] out
of him how the chair the chairs the guy
do it what yeah the tournament I have
introduced the man yet so I don't know
I'm a freestyler you're a man you know
you would like to get seduced do that
how would you do that I don't that's not
what work for you yeah if anyone did
that to me
anyway I think that's clear I think I'm
good I'm good I got a wife I can't be
doing the show be joy
it has to be a stranger yeah because
patreon for patreon can we do it there
huh we got somebody from Craigslist and
brought them here and we did it for
Pedro it's gonna work that's why I don't
want it to happen I'm already blushing
thinking about it guy or girl anybody
especially a big fat lunch lady if she
does this child I'm like oh [ __ ]
betray what would you do yeah well I
don't know man
yeah what would you do to seduce the guy
how would you seduce a man
Pedro I would take them watching sports
oh that's pretty good that's pretty game
they get pretty vulnerable dur in that
em drunk pretending to like their team
you know thinking real long-term and
then you guys start reenacting week I
saw in the field you tries to get it
before I know you have you yeah this
credit card and you're making purchases
and you're gonna go yeah okay that's how
about us to do some an everybody so
that's what this is trying to do true
man I don't think it through
[Music]